t
de 50 millions de dollars,
à l'approche de la saison
des récoltes.
Notre envoyé spécial en Bavière,
Christian Noël.
- Encore une fois, l'horreur
et la dévastation frappent les
rues de la capitale ukrainienne.
La Russie accentue ses frappes
militaires et bombarde Kiev.Unee
au sommet du G7.
Un geste brutal de la barbarie,
disent-ils, qui démontre qu'il
ne faut pas céder un pouce
à Vladimir Poutine. Plus tôt
dans la journée, les dirigeants
du G7 se sont moqués de Vladimir
Poutine.
"Devrions nous garder
nos vestons?",
demande Boris Johnson.
"Allons-y torse nu et à cheval",
renchérit Justin Trudeau,
en référence à une photo
célèbre de Vladimir Poutine.
La rencontre au sommet dans
les montagnes bavaroises devait
servir à démontrer l'harmonie
des dirigeants du G7 face à
la Russie. Pourtant, la Fran
et l'Amérique sont en désaccord
sur la façon de poursuivre
la guerre. Justin Trudeau
souhaite repousser complètement
la Russis de
l'Ukraine, alors qu'Emmanuel
Macron semble plus ouvert à
un compromis. N'empêche, le G7
prépare une nouvelle série
de sanctions.- Au plaisir d'êtrc
le premier ministre Trudeau!
- Évidemment, on va parler
de l'Ukraine, on va parler
d'inflation.
- Le Canada et la Grande-
Bretagne veulent couper le flot
de l'or vers la Russie pour
punir les oligarques et freinere
en Ukraine. Justin Trudeau
n'exclut pas des sanctions
purement canadiennes,
par exeme secteur des
technologies et de l'innovation.
Autre dossier urgent :
alimentaire.
La saison des récoltes approche
en Ukraine. La Russie a détruit
les terminaux à grain qu'il faut
rebâtir. Le Canada propose de
partager son expertise agricole.
- C'est important d'y arriver
pour favoriser le développement
durable.
- Une main tendue aux pays
qui souffrent de la crise
alimentaire causée par
e. Un dossier crucial
pour plusieurs pays comme l'Inde
et l'Afrique du Sud, invités
au sommet du G7. Devant tous
ces enjeux, en apparence
contradictoires, les dirigeants
marchent sur un fil de fer.
- Tout le monde ici s'entend
pour dire qu'on doit travailler
ensemble pour réduire les écarts
en matière d'investissements
dans lesctures dans
les pays en développement.
- C'est le dilemme des pays
du G7 : comment punir Vladimir
Poutine avec des sanctions q
lui font mal sans pour autant
nuire aux pays alliés ou à
ceux du Sud.
Ici Christian Noël,
Radio-Canada, à Garmisch-
Partenkirchen, en